everyone I have a lot of luck my channel
sorry the audio quality is not great my
microphone has decided to not work on me
but I wanted to make a quick video to
talk about the Diablo controversy I said
I wasn't gonna do it but here I am so
I'm not gonna recap the story because I
assume people watching this video
already know but Diablo modal was a
mobile game and a lot of people are very
angry and I got a little more insight
under what happened here from a group of
Blizzard employees at Blizzcon Kotaku
posted an article written by Jason trout
saying well whose tweet specifically
said that a Diablo 4 announcement was
planned for Blizzcon and was pulled last
minute that is very counter to what I
was told by Blizzard employees at
Blizzcon I tweeted in response saying
something like feel like I should say
publicly but this is not what I was told
or is you know directly against what I
was told Jason I spoke about it
privately I told him my side of the
thing I think he probably maybe reached
out to another person and got some
clarification and updated his article
but by that time I Janet already posted
their article and I think polygon had to
quoting Kotaku on what I truly believe
to be incorrect and now again I do want
to say this isn't me saying that Jason's
lying I was doing a bad job because fact
is Blizzard is a huge company people can
be told different things even within was
it so I'm not even saying that my
sources are 100% correct or that he's a
wrong it's totally possible there was an
internal miscommunication so right now
no assets exists no approved assets
exist for Diablo for James mean walked
on but yeah no no trailer exists that
that product isn't ready yet there is a
video from an employee that talks about
Diablo 4 but it was never planned to be
at Blizzcon I believe that there was
discussion about a month ago maybe two
months ago about whether or not they
would show something at Blizzcon
regarding Diablo fall but it was decided
against the reason from that from one
particular
person on the development team at
Blizzard is that supposedly they were
actually kind of proud of this mobile
game Blizzard is very good at making
games obviously you know they've had
rocky launches like Diablo 3 but for the
most part incredible quality games for
pretty hot broads the reality is in
China and Japan mobile gaming is pretty
hardcore people do it a lot and it
sounds like they were proud of the fact
that they had made a mobile game that
they think is really good it's not that
they didn't know that people would be
mad about the announcement but I think
that might have been some ego involved
there and no one said this to me
explicitly this is sort of an assumption
based on what I was told is that they
were like no mobile games aren't
accepted in the West we made a really
really goddamn good one we're gonna show
it off and we're proud of it we want it
to be a centerpiece for our investors to
care about obviously but also because we
want to prove to our fans that they will
have something they can play on the go
that's really good of course it being
developed mostly by another company car
is out the window but it sounds like
that was actually a legitimate part of
the choice that they were like no let's
not discredit this thing that we made
that is actually quality by talking
about together for as well but of course
knowing the industry it was probably
mostly for investors which wife noting
seriously if you ever want to wonder how
the game industry functions or why
decisions are made I promise you the
stock market especially for the publicly
traded companies like active lizard is
so much more important than you think
they care so much more about that than
they do about fans for the most part and
I think that's why some Diablo fans were
pissed off because this seemed like a
very investor friendly move at a fan
facing conference but stocks did drop
6% even though that game is gonna make
so much goddamn money obviously they
miscalculated the reaction but I do
believe that was conversation that and
that it was decided against to make a
day before announcement in advance in
place of making that announcement they
did put up a post saying
to be too excited they put up that video
saying that there are multiple Diablo
projects in the works so they were
trying to like talk about Diablo without
having it be a big reveal at this event
as mentioned in part because they wanted
their mobile game to have its own
announcement but also in part because
it's just absolutely not ready to show
yet and the exact same thing would apply
if they announce yellow four too soon
and then it doesn't release for four
years we know people get mad about that
[ __ ] or if they announce it too soon
with like a gameplay trailer and then
the game looks different because it's so
far away people will get mad about that
[ __ ] obviously people who mad anyway but
historically announcing games way before
they're ready generally makes game is
angry so it's not a good idea it also
makes marketing harder and I spoke about
this in my video about yay which if you
haven't seen that I talked a lot about
how publishers approach conferences and
how important investors are but there's
this thing called revenue recognition
it's difficult to explain but in these
simplest terms the way it works in the
games industry is that the minute you've
announced something or you have shown
investors that you have spent money on
marketing it you have to have a plan for
the return on that investment so for
example to announced yeah blow a model
they depending on how the or the
corporation works specifically fiscally
they probably have to get some return on
the revenue they have provably spent on
that marketing back so investors aren't
like hold up you guys spent money
marketing that where is the money from
it basically that means that companies
can lose a ton of money on the stock
market if they announce something way
too soon and investors don't have a
guarantee of money returned on the
marketing expense and the truth is
investors madelung games do so again I
can't tell you with absolute certainty
that what I heard is more accurate than
what everyone else had I think the thing
that really backs this up is that they
did say don't get too excited I think
that they had always planned to make
this one announcement at Blizzcon and
someone on the community team was
eventually like hmm people might be mad
about this and so they released a blog
post saying
don't get too hyped I do not believe a
Diablo 4 announcement was planned who
Blizzcon that was pulled last minute and
I want to say I actually don't buy into
the whole entitled gameis thing this
time around I understand why people are
mad I get that if you are part of a
hardcore audience you've bought a ticket
to a convention that isn't cheap hotels
flights potentially because you're such
a big Diablo fan and you go there and
that's the only thing they announce off
to telling you to be excited about
Diablo like I completely get why people
are mad you're allowed to be critical
especially of a enormous corporation
like Activision Blizzard they make so
much goddamn money thing out so good at
monetizing but you know don't be a dick
there is definitely something to be said
about the fact that Blizzard benefits
enormous ly off of fans and you know
publishers and developers spend so much
money and so many marketing resources on
trying to make people hardcore fans but
then it's a concern to them when people
are fans then they're so invested that
they're angry about a choice like
frankly I do think we should call our
publishers when they do something wrong
already everyone I want and I will see
you guys next time okay